we've shown a spotlight on the
importance of protecting media freedom
and how
how advancing the status of women and
girls is an investment in the success
for our democracies and we focused on
the need to empower human rights
defenders and make sure technological
and
technology enables so much of our lives
that is used to advance democracies to
lift people up not to hold them down
we've heard the concerns of young people
who have
had a greater stake in the future than
anyone else and they've made that clear
about what matters to them most and how
important it is to make sure their
voices are included in our democracies
and so each of our nations faces unique
challenges
and many of the specific circumstances
are different the threat we face
and the solutions we seek have a common
antecedent
this is not a struggle of anyone facing
it alone it's all of us and the
commitments we've made to ourselves to
our own people to one another will not
only strengthen our own democracies by
pushing back against autocracies
fighting corruption and promoting human
rights
for all people this is going to help
seed fertile ground for democracy to
bloom around the world
and i'm so encouraged by the energy and
enthusiasm we've seen to rally people
around the world in support of our
shared democratic values
as just one example
in advance of the summit the presidents
of panama costa rica and the dominican
republic formed quote an alliance to
strengthen democratic institutions and a
quote to cooperate to cooperate on
transparency human rights economic
development
and strengthening democracy throughout
the region this is a sort of inspiring
commitment and partnerships that i hope
we'll see more of as you undertake this
issue in the next year of action
and i hope that each of our countries
are going to measure the results of our
efforts so that we can report back on
our progress at a second summit for
democracy next year and i hope to
welcome each of you in person
for the for our part as i said yesterday
the united states is committed to
strengthening our democracy at home and
to working with parties around the world
around the globe to prove that
democracies can deliver for people on
issues that matter most to them
here at home
that means working to make real the full
promise of america including by enacting
both the freedom to vote act and the
john lewis voting rights advancement act
because what's true around the world is
also true in the united states
the sacred right to vote to vote freely
the right to have your vote counted is
the threshold liberty for democracy
for every democracy
within anything's possible without it
virtually nothing is possible so we have
to come together and get it done and we
will
the united states is also going to
continue efforts to beat the pandemic
working with the world health
organization kovacs and other partners
to save lives vaccinate the world
against covet 19 and advance health
security for everyone
we're leveraging our democratic
partnerships like the g7 and the quad to
amplify our shared capacity to produce
and deliver vaccines and help get shots
and arms for everyone everywhere
we're taking on climate crisis the
climate crisis with a seriousness and
urgency responding to the moral with
moral clarity we're seeing coming from
young people around the world
we're affirming the democratic values
that are at the heart of our
international system
and which have been the foundational
elements of for decades from global
growth and prosperity
and we're committed we're committed to
working with all who share those values
to shape the rules of the road that are
going to govern our progress in the 21st
century
including on issues of cyber security
and emerging technologies so the future
generations continue to reap the
benefits of liberty and democracy as we
have the final message i want to impart
as we close out this summit for
democracy
is that we know how hard the work is is
going to be ahead of us but we also know
we are up to the challenge
because i've said before
and as this gathering has demonstrated
the democratic world is everywhere
autocracies can never extinguish the
ember of liberty that burns in the
hearts of people around the world in
every portion of the world
it knows no borders
it speaks every language
it lives in anti-corruption activists
human rights defenders
journalists peaceful protesters and the
front lines of this struggle all around
the world
it lives in town council meetings union
elections
daily small acts that occur around the
globe whenever people come together to
solve problems and to bridge differences
and in all the ways civil society
empowers individuals to have a direct
say in the issues that impact on their
their lives that impact on them
personally
and so defending democracy demands a
whole of society effort
requires all of us
the leaders of governments we we have a
responsibility to listen to our citizens
to strengthen the guardrails of
democracy and to drive reforms that are
going to make transparent accountable
governments governments more resilient
against the buffering and the buffeting
forces of autocracy
and those who want a naked pursuit of
power ahead of the public good
you know we have to work together with
the private sector to combat corruption
to build more equitable economies where
more people can share the benefits
we have to empower our citizens to hold
accountable
pull all of us accountable the highest
ideals and to make sure our actions
align with our words
and as we close out the first gathering
let's let
us together reaffirm our determination
that the future will belong to those who
embrace human dignity
not those who trample
who unleash the potential of their
people
not those who stifle it
and who give their people the ability to
breathe free
not those who seek to suffocate their
people with an iron hand
you know as the great irish poet sheamus
haney once wrote
once in a lifetime a long forward tidal
wave of justice can rise up
and hope and history rhyme
that tidal wave doesn't come out of
nowhere it doesn't happen by accident
it happens because people unleash the
irresistible power
of their dreams and their determination
democracy is what makes it possible for
hope and history to rhyme
and today
open history lie in our hands
so let's raise up
our ambitions and rise up to meet the
challenges together
thank you and i look forward to
following through in the next year on
all the commitments we're making
individually thank you
[Music]
pretty precious
and i think you'll see it change uh
um sooner than quicker than more rapidly
it will take than most people think
every other aspect of the economy is
racing ahead
it's doing incredibly well
we've never had this kind of growth in
60 years
but inflation is affecting people's
lives but if you take a look at it if
you if we were
if and when god willing we get the bill
back better proposal
if you look at what what what's
inflation all about for people
they're paying more for things they need
than they had to pay before
that's the bottom line
now if they're paying considerably less
for child care
consider it less for health care
considerably that's for insulin
considerably that's and go down the list
of being able to take care of their
parent all the things that are in the
build back better plan
the reason why people think it's going
to economists think it's going to in
fact diminish the impact on inflation is
because it's reducing costs for ordinary
people
reducing costs for ordinary people
so i think it's but in the meantime
by the in order to get that up and
running
and we don't have a single republican
willing to support it yet in order to
get that up and running it's going to be
focused all on the downside the downside
is prices have gone up because of supply
chain concerns
we've worked as hard on the supply chain
concerns i think you're going to see
you've already begun to see and you're
going to see over the next couple months
oil prices gap prices of gas pump come
down
you know the biggest
one one of the third of the increase in
inflation is used automobiles
um so i mean it is a real problem
but the point is that has to do with
supply chain as well but it also has to
do with the fact that not everybody's
looking for a used automobile but those
who are they're paying higher prices
because there's fewer of them because of
the cobit and what was sold out and the
like so i think it's uh it really is
it's a real bump in the road it does
affect families when you walk in the
grocery store and you're paying more for
whatever you're purchasing it matters it
matters to people when you're paying
more for gas although in some states
we've got the price down below three
bucks a gallon but the point is
it's not gone down quickly enough
but i think it
will next step on ukraine
well i i i don't know the answer that
i'm going to be talking to him beginning
of the week
and
and i think if you look at what most
people are saying most economists are
saying
this build back better bill is not going
to increase inflation it'll diminish
inflation it has a negative impact on
inflation
it doesn't raise inflation
but that's hard for people to think
about right now because inflation is up
and there's a direct correlation of most
people's mind why is inflation will
government spend the money well that's
not the reason for the inflation the
reason for the inflation is that we have
a supply chain problem that is really
severe and is causing a significant
increase in prices and things that in
fact are hard to get access to because
at the bottom the bottom of all is
covered covet has had a serious impact
on the ability to produce a whole lot of
necessary products particularly those
imported uh from
uh from the pacific and other places
i'll take your
questions to the supreme court leaving
the texas abortion law in place and what
specifically are you going to do well my
problem is i haven't seen i just got
back i just walked here from delivering
bob dole's eulogy so i haven't seen
the report i will take a look at what
the supreme court said i don't know what
it said
i don't know what it said because the
last three hours i've been
involved with bob dole's eulogy and
funeral and uh but i will i will have a
comment
well i don't i'm not going to comment on
something i don't know yet but i will
comment thank you all so very much
you